في مستجدات الحر في اوكرانيا افادت وكاله
الانباء الاوكرانيه بان سلطات البلاد
تمكنت من استعاده نحو 80% من الطاقه التي
تنبح احتياجات الاستهلاك ليبلغ العجز 20%
فقط
واضافت الوكاله ان جهود استعاده الكهرباء
جاريه بعد سبع هجمه روسيه على البنيه
التحتيه للطاقه في البلاد
في غضون ذلك تساقطت الثلوج بغزاره في
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف مع انخفاض درجات
الحراره الى ما دون الصفر بينما لا يزال
ملايين الاشخاص يعيشون في المدينه
والمناطق المحيطه بها بلا كهرباء او تدفئه
وفي التطورات الميدانيه ايضا تعرضت منطقه
ديني برو بتروجيسك وسط اوكرانيا الى خمس
هجمات روسيه من قاذفات الصواريخ متعدده
ومتفاعيه ثقيله ما ادى لتدمير العديد من
منشات البنيه التحتيه حسب حاكم المدينه
فالنتين ريشكو وفي الشرق قصفت القوات
الاوكرانيه وسط مدينه
الصحفي محمد الباب محمد اهلا وسهلا بك
جديد المشهد بنكييف محمد اخر اخبار القصف
الروسي بدايه قبل ان اسالك عن موضوع
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي وكذلك موضوع
التدفئه
نعم بالفعل يعني يستمر القذف الروسي على
المناطق المحايده للمقاطعات التي سيطرت
عليها روسيا مثلا
ضد اليوم وظهر هذا اليوم لقصف مدفعي
وشاروخي مدينه الميكروفون لا تزال تتعرض
منذ مساء الامس الى ضربات صاروخيه ومدفعيه
طالت منشات البناء التحتيه من محطات
لتوليد الطاقه الكهربائيه التي كانت تعمل
فرق الصيانه في تلك المدينه على صيانتها
ولكن الجيش الروسي يستمر بقصف تلك المنطقه
مدينه خارطه ايضا تعرضت لقصف مدعي وصاروخي
وسقطت اكثر من اربع صواريخ 300 على حي- في
في تلك المدينه مما ادى الى مقتل شخص
واصابه سته اخر يعني يستمر التصعيد في تلك
المنطقه هناك استراتيجيه جديده روسيه
نراها وهي تكثيف القصف على المدن
الاوكرانيه منذ السحابها من مدينه خرسون
بدوره الجيش الاوكراني ايضا اعلن انه قصف
احد المراكز التي تعتبر مركز عسكري كبير
داخل مدينه دونيستا هو فندق يقع بالقرب من
الملعب همم فندق فيكتوريا حيث يستخدمه
القوات الروسيه كما قياده وتجمع للقوات
الروسيه الجيش الاوكراني قصف هذا يعني هذا
الفندق مما ادى يعني حسب المعلومات هناك
قتلى وجرحه في صفوف القوات الروسيه عسكريه
او ميدانيا الجيش الاوكراني حاول التقدم
في قطاع اللوجان مدينه فقاسنا الا انه
يواجه اشتباكات عريقه عنيفه وتبادل للقصف
بمدافع الهاون بينه وبين القوات الروسيه
التي تحاول الحفاظ على خطوطها الدفاعيه في
تلك المنطقه
الروسي في محور جنوب مدينه محور اديداس
كامريكا ايضا يحاول التقدم ولكنه يستخدم
جيش الاوكراني والخطوط الدفاعيه للجيش
الاوكراني طيب بالنسبه لموضوع الكهرباء
والتدفئه كما نشاهد من وراءك كيف تتعرض
لعاصفه الثلجيه بالطبع التوقعات بشتاء
قارس هل الكهرباء مؤمنه في جميع احياء
اكياس هل التدفئه مؤمنه ايضا في جميع
احياء كيف محمد
نعم يعني يمكن القول منذ مساء الامس وحتى
ساعات الصباح الاولى بدا تحسن في تزويد
سكان العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف تيار
الكهربائي اليوم هو افضل من الغد وغدا
افضل من اليوم هذه ما قاله عمده خلال
مداخله معك القنوات الاوكرانيه التي قال
ان فرق الصيانه تعمل على يعني على جميع
يعني المحطات التي تم قصفها خلال الاسبوع
الماضي ولكن كان هناك موقف ليه
مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني وايضا جاي في
الارقام يعني كبير مفودين الاوكرانيين
الذي قال ان السلطات الاوكرانيه تستعد
لضربات صاروخيه مقبلات قد تكون الاسبوع
المقبل على غرار ما حصل خلال الاسابيع
الاربع الماضيه بس تكون روسيا يعني الجانب
الاوكراني يستعد لضربات ستكون مباشره
الطاقه وواحف لك
اسوا سيناريو قد يكون وهو انقطاع تيار
كهربائي بشكل كبير طيب سؤال اخير محمد
باختصار الاوروبيون قالوا انهم ارسلوا
مولدات طاقه بالالاف الى السلطات
الاوكرانيه في محاوله منهم لسد النقص هل
وصلت هذه المولدات وفق همم معلوماتك والى
ماذا يعني تستطيع سد النقص فعليا
يعني هذه المولدات
يعني المطلوب ولكن كان هناك ايضا مساعدات
لوجستيه وهي محولات بديله التي تم قصفها
وتصل دفاعا بشكل مستمر تصل هذه المساعدات
هذه الجزئيه ولكن هناك خبر مهم يتداول
الان في اوكراني خبر مهم جدا ان رئيس شركه
وهي الشركه المولده او التي تدير مفاعل
زفولوجيا قال ان للشركه مؤشرات
ودلائل انك قوات الروسيه تستعد للخروج من
مفاعل الخروج هذا خبر يتبول بشكل كبير في
وسائل
الصحفي محمد شكرا لك يا محمد على كل هذه
المتابعه
الان ينضم الي من هناك مراسل العربيه اهلا
وسهلا بك المشهد من عندك كيف يبدو تحديدا
اخر الاخبار المتواتره عن القصف الاوكراني
لبعض احياء دونتس
طالب مساء الخير بالفعل منذ الصباح الباكر
والقوات الاخرانيه تقصف مناطق متفرقه في
مقاطعه
بالفعل اعلنت الدفاع الروسيه ايضا عن هجمه
اوكرانيه على مقابل
المحور الذي شنته هذه الى جماعه
الاوكرانيه والقوات الاوكرانيه لكن نحن
هنا في قلب العاصمه دليت سبعه او ثمانيه
وصواريخ في مناطق المتفرقه قريبه من مكان
اقامتنا حقيقه كان المشهد مفزع جدا ارعنا
الى المراجع يعني انتظرنا حوالي ساعه حتى
خرجنا لنحصل على بعض الصور ونرسلها همم
هناك هجمات همم عنيفه من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه نحن شهود عيان على سقوط
القذائف في قلب العاصمه ايضا هناك تسقط في
احياء متفرقه على اطراف الايه المقاطعه
همم حي همم كيف سيحي كيروسكي همم قتلها
ثلاثه واعداد فرديه من الاصابات خلال
الفتره الماضيه همم بالفعل هناك همم هجوم
اوكراني عنيف على محاور مختلفه ايضا من
منطقه لنتكلم عن المعارك بشكل عام طالب من
منطقه همم مقاطعه خارطه
تشمنا القوات الاوكرانيه ايضا هجمات على
المقاطعه اللغز نحو مدينتي سيفردان
التاني اا يعني سيطر عليهم الجيش الروسي
وايضا منها جماعه نحوه مركز الجيش الروسي
في مدينه كريمنا يا عبر اصوات مدينه
المحور الذي يتبادل في الطرفان القصب هناك
ايضا اسلحه استراتيجيه روسيه وصلت طرف
الانفصاليون هنا في دانيت وتقول السلطات
الانفصاليه انها
ايطر على اطراف مدينتي مارينكا والديفكا
حيث تلقينا مع مقاتلين من الشيشان وقالوا
انهم بالفعل همم دخلوا الى مئات الامطار
في اطراف مدينه ماركا المتاخمه لمدينه
دانيه نعم المعارك همم
بالنسبه الى الكهرباء التدفئه يعني ثمنه
شهر ايضا في عاصفه كمان يعني تضرب شمال
همم
شرق اوكرانيا بالنسبه الى الكهرباء وسائل
التدفئه مؤمنا في دوناتس ام لا هنالك همم
انقطاع او شبه انقطاع
يعني في الحديث عن الاجانب الانسان يطالب
لابد من الحديث عن انقطاع الماء منذ
انطلاق العمليه العسكريه القوات
الاوكرانيه تحجز المياه عن مقاطعه
خلف المياه ابار المياه
والمحطات تنقيه تقع خلف مدينه سلابيان حيث
نهر السوبر جانيت التي هذه المنطقه تسيطر
عليها القوات
الاوكرانيها تدخل المياه من روسيا لهذه
المناطق كل ثلاثه ايام ساعتين فقط مساء لا
تصل الى الادوار العليا الى الدور الارض
فقط ويذهب الناس للنشر ونهل المياه خلال
هاتين الساعتين كالجراد بالفعل همم الوضع
سيء هنا المدن التي انتهت فيها المعارك
همم
بل بعض النظافه
لم تصل اليها خدمات الغاز حتى الان لكن
الماء
وبقى يعني متوفرين والجهات المقوله باعاده
الاعمار والبناء
لايصال كل الخدمات للمواطنين ونحن على
ابواب الشتاء والبرد
مراسل العربيه رائد الاكبر شكرا جزيلا لك
رائد على كل هذه المتابعه